Michigan State University is moving to
fired the ex boss of former US a
gymnastics doctor that's Larry now sir
dr. William strepa was arranged as a
rain rather on four charges yesterday
the 70 year old is accused of criminal
sexual misconduct involving medical
school school students now his attorney
denies these charges stemple was
Michigan State Dean of osteopathic
medicine when NASA worked for the school
dr. Jon LaPook has covered this story
extensively from the very beginning John
good morning morning gale MSU says it
will remove employees who do not treat
students faculty staff or anyone else in
their community in an appropriate manner
the charges against Williams trampled
surface during an investigation into how
the university handled complaints
against Nasr sir are you Williams
trample appearing on video from a
Michigan jail
Williams trampled was arraigned on four
charges a felony count of misconduct in
office and three misdemeanors including
one count of criminal sexual conduct and
two counts of willful neglect of duty he
may not have any contact with any victim
any witness in a court affidavit for
female Michigan State medical students
alleged multiple incidents of sexual
misconduct against trampel including two
who told police Stram polier dat them
and groped them all four told police
trample made sexually suggestive
comments to them
John dak MCUs tramples attorney my
client denies that he ever engaged in
any inappropriate touching of anyone any
student or otherwise strand pool is also
accused of neglect of duty for failing
to supervise Nasr who is now in prison
for sexually abusing more than 250 young
women a lot of people are asking how to
master get away with this for so long
does this help in some way answer that
yeah because it shows that it wasn't
just NASA in 2014 former Michigan State
University student Amanda Thomas show
filed a complaint against NASA for
sexual abuse although a university
investigation cleared Nasr of misconduct
Stram poland' nasa when notified about
significant problems with nasa's
practice the very person who was
supposed to be looking after nasa turns
out that he was also doing things that
were inappropriate allegedly
don't think anything could shock me at
this point I'm just dying to know how
deep this runs and who knew about it
following the investigation at atomic
shows complaint
Stram poll did establish guidelines for
NASA to follow during exams but Nora
according to yesterday's complaint
strata did not actually enforce or
monitor those protocols strapless up to
nine years in prison disgusting there
all the details John thank you so much